welcome back to this week in startups
it's our nine hundred and something
episode and Jackie Emmy award-winning
producer Jackie has committed that the
next 100 episodes as we lead into number
1,000 will be a unicorn investor CEO or
founder each time Jackie what a
challenge you've got the first two
you've got 98 to go I love how Jackie
anywhere producer Jackie sets her own
stretch goals incredible jacket when you
told me you were gonna get a hundred
unicorns for me in the next hundred
episodes I was flabbergasted by the
ambition stretch goals stretch goal what
a stretch of a beautiful thing and it's
so great to have SendGrid on the program
because we love and you sang great you
may or may not know this your comm is
powered by SendGrid and we love it
amazing I'll give you the look of my
fabulous we had many choices of who to
go with yeah and we did the heads up
bake-off SendGrid and the mighty Amazon
Web Services mm-hmm sangra trounced it
whoo better delivery yes better delivery
better API documentation I bet
everything and the team is very humble
think when we speak to them and they're
very helpful good a bunch of other ages
but so so proud to hear that and thank
Dave for doing that but that is that
brings up a good point
when did AWS because it was on your
watch decided they would get into
transient categorical transactional
email you're in that where we started
that's right that's we stern yeah
when AWS came into that space what year
were you in in your tenure and then what
was that board meeting like cuz you must
have known they were gonna come
eventually I think the team did again
predated my arrival so if I went back
and looked I want to say it was 2012
looking for a fact check so either 2011
either late 11 or mid 2012 somewhere in
that time zone ah and and they came into
the market and as you would imagine you
know having had lots of conversations
with the board and previous management
team there that was in OH
blank kind of a day that was an issue oh
man yes Oh ich ich moment and what was
remarkable coming out of it is that it
fueled sin grid's growth it actually was
an accelerated right totally yeah not
what you play unpack it so here's what
ends up happening Amazon
being AWS legitimizes the need for every
developer on the planet to use a service
like this as opposed to rolling their
own as opposed rolling their own that
was your big competitor with somebody
just throws up whatever that's you now
serve or whatever it is maybe we can do
this ourselves oh just a server Do It
Yourself DIY we'll set up a couple mail
servers set up you know the SMTP
protocol will be all good and and so
they legitimized every developer needs
one of these create a bunch of demand
and awareness for the need and then the
developers being awesome developers
would say well I wonder if anybody else
does this let me do a quick search they
would find us and then compare the two
and thankfully they all had the exact
same experience that you did focus
matters and then they would and say wow
these SendGrid folks have been doing
exactly this and nothing about this for
years that's all they're gonna do and
you know we we're off to the races
this is we're in the competitive
landscape let's keep pulling this string
a little bit and see where it leads us
MailChimp I know did mandrill that's
right
the transactional email service went
head-to-head with you but then they they
deprecated that I guess they didn't down
yeah they got out of the business they
got out of the business as a standalone
service they still offer it to their
marketing customers but in terms of a
developer looking for a transactional
email solution they got out of that
business how would you describe
MailChimp versus SendGrid here in 2019
what are the differences between those
two platforms I would say they're
MailChimp kind of reverted to their
roots as a email marketing provider and
and I think you know I would say
selfishly we would say or perhaps you
know in our in our world view recognized
that we were we send grid we're going to
continue to do what we do distinctively
well and at a scale that would be hard
for them to match and that they would be
better served continuing to focus on
their core customer as the marketer and
to their great credit
we have immense respect for the
MailChimp team but they're going after
marketers but they're going after
marketers I want to build a database and
have some beautiful templates I'll use
MailChimp I'm a developer and I need to
send whatever million
billions of transactional email every
time you get a friend request every time
you get a comment on a post yeah a
reminder whatever you're gonna use sent
you using grid and that was where so
that's where we started and when I
joined the company I would say to their
credit mandrill had and the MailChimp
team had done a nice job they innovated
in in some areas that where we were so
busy scaling with our customers
we're like literally just trying to keep
up with the service so it didn't fall
over because the demand was so great on
it more of our energy was going into
scaling than it was into innovating
mandrill added a couple a set of things
that were interesting and I remember
when I first joined it was my assessment
that mandrill was sort of eating our
lunch and the low end of the market in
particular they undercut us on price
materially and they had a bunch of cool
new features that we did not and so I
remember when we joined 2015 we set up a
tiger team and said and they had one of
those pages on their website that was
you know the list of here all the
capabilities mandrill check SendGrid x
mandrill check SendGrid X and we said to
the tiger team we want one of those to
come down every month Wow here's your
road map your road map go take them down
one by one and we're gonna close it down
do you then call out and we literally
had our Dan trail okay yeah our John
Council called theirs and said that's no
longer true please please remove also
longer true because we were doing
marketing like that and it's not factual
laughs actually correct yeah that's not
cool you can't do that so every month we
are GC would make a call and say that's
no longer true and about six months in
they took the page down and then about
nine months in is when they announced
that they were gonna get out of the
standalone market let me ask you a
question about cuz I don't understand
all this stuff deliverability yes yeah
I'm a huge fan of email yeah because I
watched trying to make it work with
Google search and being disintermediated
social media being disintermediate like
and then apps like you're constantly
YouTube the people who are running those
ecosystems change the rules yeah and you
lose access to your actual customers
that you build up your friends and
followers right they just absolutely
rotated immediately so I said you know
what screw it I'm gonna take you inside
calm yeah and make an email newsletter
company yeah
and then I started wondering am I gonna
be at risk of Gmail specifically Google
and Gmail disintermediating me again and
sure enough they put up these four tabs
mmm yeah promotions forum social social
yeah was that a move to control
marketing into the email box or in users
best interest or somewhere in between
cuz the cynic in me believes yeah that
they were trying not just to make life
easier for users but maybe negate
people's ability to get marketers
ability to get into inboxes yeah what do
you think I I actually I J I think it
genuinely came from a place of wanting
to improve the the user experience what
we found that was remarkable was from
the introduction of the tabs and we had
as you would imagine lots of customers
who were very concerned about it like
sure oh my gosh where what's gonna do to
my open rates and I click-through rates
and that drives a lot of revenue for our
customers and what was remarkable it
actually didn't have a material impact
for a couple of reasons
one I think it's something on the order
of about sixty something percent of the
emails we deliver on behalf of our
whatever our latest public number was
seventy thousand I think was the latest
public 74,000 paying customers another
120,000 free customers they why was I
going with that oh deliverability sixty
percent
oh that sixty percent are opened on a
mobile device oh and you know what on a
mobile device there are no tabs yeah as
it turns out yeah and because just the
form factor you can't you don't do the
taps and so and those that were on
desktop it didn't have as big of an
impact on open and click-through rates
because the people that really cared
they were engaged with the brand's they
went down them it does seem that those
brands also when you email with and when
you interact with emailing your
promotions tab yeah
or you one of those other tabs that's
not the inbox does it automatically
Gmail send it over to your main box
that's something I've been trying to
figure out like so let's say you read
strategy every day we're inside San Fran
every day yeah if you're opening it
every day and it's in your promotions
tab yeah does it does it automatically
move it over that's a good question they
use so much machine learning over there
I'd be shocked if it didn't I know that
from my own experience having used it it
will it's it's a case very simple click
to say move to my to my my primary and
primary tab
my primary Inbox email is having a huge
resurgence yes like the last year or two
has been amazing how every startup and
all these companies are saying we got to
get back to email yeah I when we get
back from this quick break I want to
know what's behind that and then what
kind of what is the value of an email
subscriber versus or an email address
versus like say having a follower on a
social network when we get back on this
week in startups
[Music]